hey guys i'm with you Caro Nakamura who
just finished his game tell us a little
bit about your final gaming your
impressions on the tour so far ok um
well I was very disappointed with the
opening I was kind of expecting veselin
to try something a bit more aggressive I
Frank was hoping for a more progressive
game myself than what happened but of
course after such a long tournament
where veselin obviously was not playing
his best it was very practical choice
and after that um I just tried to get
something but I think for the most part
is equal and then at the end I kind of
started just losing a little bit trying
a little bit too hard i think maybe at
the end even i was looking a little bit
worse but um but he kind of did not he
didn't want to try and i don't blame him
considering his results so draws a
pretty pretty pretty pretty reasonable
result for both of us as far as the to
her goes i thought i thought it was a
interesting experiment certainly uh I
didn't think it was that much different
than then when I play the tournament's
of stand-alones but anytime their new
ideas things too despite sup chests it's
generally good thing so um so yeah I was
Susan I enjoyed it perhaps I didn't
enjoy the tournament here that much but
overall it was a good experience it's
really gonna add some drama tonight now
if you had to play in a grand chest or
competition and you had to have a non
chest related playoff what would you
pick um I don't know I think I think a
lot of chess players are good at various
games or sports but it was not just I I
don't think you can really do it because
the language barriers and then the fact
that everyone has their different
strengths but maybe if there's some some
some game of logic or something like
that maybe would be for you to win
something that you for me to win uh well
i don't know i think the most
interesting one was would be if I played
griffix I think there are multiple games
that we'd be pretty competitive out
besides chess so maybe something like
poker back Yemen
maybe bridge perhaps something along
those lines but uh anyway that's that's
not the case but it would certainly be
something that I would think about and
I'm sure there's something that I'm good
at yes a lot of things I'm sure well
we're here a p-card Nakamura and it
looks like we're gonna be in for a long
and exciting night on the first season
of the grand chest or back to you guys